i was 11  turning 12 going to the seventh no no i  was no no no it was my seventh to eighth  grade summer  my shoot my foot went from an 11 to a  half  to 18 where it's at now  the worst summer ever  i literally had no pair of shoes  my mom got me a pair of obviously  remember the iversons that um  that zipped up and then the j kids that  um you can take the skin off with the uh  gary payton's and the scottie tippins i  had i had those for the entire summer  it rained one night  i left them outside oh so i had the hoop  in those all  summer  literally that's the reason why i got so  many bad shoes now  like that's a good one there's a great  one you hit 11 to an 18. i went from 11  to 18 in like [ __ ] six weeks  nice  that's tough